this landscape may look idyllic but
something important is missing there are
no large predators in mountain zebra
National Park which was established some
seventy years ago but that's about to
change
cheetahs will once again hunt these
grounds
researcher Kelly Marnie wick is working
with two males that are being relocated
to the park named Batman and Robin the
dynamic duo will restore the parks
predator-prey balance while helping out
some of South Africa's wild game farmers
the devote wild cheetah project started
in the year 2000 as a result of conflict
experience between farmers and cheetahs
the phones are priced to vote with their
problems with cheetahs and Austin so
please come up a solution to the
conflict to better understand the
conflict researchers have been
monitoring the cheetahs movements by
outfitting the animals with a GPS cell
phone caller Kelly can follow their
routes on her computer and from this
website we can see where our cheetahs
are walking and where their being even
even when we couldn't find them or see
them regular updates show when a cheetah
trespasses on a farm
and you can see these brown lancia
represent foam boundaries and you can
see how the easy she's moving in and out
of game fencing as a last resort when a
cheater causes too much damage on a farm
it must be captured and relocated the
problem cheetahs get a thorough
veterinarian checkup
once finished with the preparations the
team sets off across country to the
Cheetahs new home after arriving at
Mountain zebra National Park the Rangers
put Batman and Robin in an enclosure
called a boma here they acclimatize to
the local surroundings and the locals
acclimatize to them I have to say when
we first brought them here they arrived
and we put them in the boma we had a
line of spring back lined up on the
other side because they will really know
what was going on and the monkeys were
such a cheetah
they know now that there's a predator in
the area after several months it's time
to release the Cheetahs into the park
the Rangers tempt Batman and Robin out
of their enclosure with a carcass but
this will be their last hand-fed meal
from now on they will hunt their own
frayed bark Rangers use radio powers to
monitor the cheetahs closely
but within a few days the cat's slip
into stealth mode
and go off the radar
mix however some grisly remains suggest
the males are adapting well as for the
zebras and other game their idyllic life
may be over
but the picture of a healthy ecosystem
is looking more complete
sponsored by National Geographic mission
programs taking science and exploration
into the new millennium